hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm katie do
ba Katie and I are gonna watch the
trailer for a movie I'm very excited is
coming out it's called hardcore I saw
the footage they put together for this
movie in order to get the Kickstarter
campaign Wow Wow
Katie did not see the footage so there's
gonna be a total surprise for her let's
see if she responds well
blow head me relax okay activate the
next part my heart
squeeze do you remember how you got here
memory is a funny thing I don't know if
you'll ever get yours the truth is
you're special
how'd you like to you
you can fluff
you're gonna need to take a few along
the way well the good news is that
you're gonna live a while back is it in
this case twenty thirty minutes tops
kill the morrow let it [ __ ] war baby
Wow
that's hardcore
that is hard here we are gourd that is
hardcore when I saw the footage I didn't
realize we're gonna make this sort of
like a sci-fi kind of action film that's
pretty cool that I feel like in the
theatre it's gonna be an awesome
experience like it's already cool
looking at the footage of this I I like
how they released a full action sequence
online first that full action sequence
shows you much better than what the
trailer shows you of how this film is
actually gonna work and operate still
just seeing this like imagine being in
the theater looking at that like a giant
[ __ ] screen
everything's first-person point of view
it's like you're part of the action
movie yeah that's gonna be [ __ ]
awesome it feels like crank but
first-person point of view
did you see crank you know anything
about it with Jason Statham how he has
to like keep his heart rate up it's an
adrenaline based kind of film and I'm
just getting revenge that fun it looks
like crank my first-person point of view
just that it reminds me it's got this
great video game format you know this P
would be like that we're getting used to
in video games and that's what makes the
action so fun and I think that's part of
the experience is gonna make it feel so
much more interactive yeah oh dude okay
but I don't know if I'm down for like
insane gross violence like when he was
doing that those things you know where
that leg I know when he's looking at
everyone I don't he's gonna be like oh
like turn away we're seeing this alter
his point of view so we see that I don't
know how much that I can handle I don't
think we heard his voice at any point
did we I'm not sure if we ever hear his
voice yeah maybe he doesn't talk maybe I
think they want to give you like an
experience as if you're this person
right right
key magic they did this like in the
oculus rift that's like you put on those
like that giant thing what is it yeah
yeah three six yeah old experience no
would be bad people they should come up
with that I heard they have it for now
you know that there's oculus rift porn
this is like you really feel like you're
having sex with the person that seems
like a natural progression though people
always want more at a porn yeah
Katie walked in there was born on my
computer right there one thing I'm
really hoping they can do to that will
not just make this film that much better
that much cooler if they have unique
action sequences as well you know it's
one thing to do the whole first person
thing but I've seen action movies and
I'm like the action still feels generic
yes big-budget and [ __ ] but it still
feels rather generic if they can
choreograph unique styles unique action
sequences and then put in the
first-person point of view then I feel
like we got a really solid action film
well I think we got glimpses of that
though we got yeah glimmers of hope like
when he's going through that big open
structure and all of a sudden the guy is
like falling down in front of them and
he just pops him up like that kind of
timing yeah it's gonna be through this
whole thing well and I think one thing
this movie needs in order to sell more
is it does need a red band trailer
that's called hardcore so you know
they're cutting back a lot on the
violence in this trailer I feel like we
need a red band trailer so that way
people can really see and feel like this
is gonna be an intense and awesome
[ __ ] film you know it's one of those
films where violence is gonna be a big
part in enjoying this movie like actual
like blood and [ __ ] I feel like we're
gonna want I don't want some pg-13
[ __ ] no no no but I don't want to
see someone's face blown off I've known
I want to see like a penis get ripped
off really I want to see like someone
like carve out their butthole first
person point of view I want to see this
guy eat of a China no you don't like you
don't want to see that these are all the
things I haven't fantasized about now
this is what happen again it's a porn in
early age we talked about this Katie
you want to become a camera man look at
the effects look at the effects it has
on kids don't do this Denis q if you're
watching this video to stop watching
don't do it
jinx is calling me jinx is calling me
hello what's up man what are you doing
okay cool
yeah yeah well thank you man that means
a lot that you'd call and say that
seriously well congratulations on a
million subs by the way yeah yeah they
reloaded right all right cool Matt well
thank you I'm actually like right in the
middle of filming a video but I had to
see why you were calling me so yeah I
was like oh [ __ ] did I say something all
right
all right cool man thanks well
congratulations again bye anyway I was
jinx another reactor thanks for tuning
into the channel if you're new to it you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
could check out Katie's channel on the
Katie do blah channel starring Katie
Dubois Dubai what is it du Bois I'm here
you're right this whole time yeah
thought I just been walking you know
dammit
and you can follow me on Facebook
Instagram Twitter buying a periscope
she's a Twitter and Instagram I do yep
as far she goes in her life
sorry I mean to put you down I only I
only do that when the cameras when the
cameras rolling is the only time I put
you down in front
Wow Wow oh stop stabbing me with your
imaginary knight delicate I believe it
when it happens
Logan G Sizemore dear Ryan can I please
have a shout out da Dada Dada da you
want me to do a lot of reactions to a
lot of things with the list that's a
list it's a list 10 facts about I've
done the porn one trust me the forum
ones I'm always going to cover so yeah
Logan s Sizemore let's see if I can make
a funny about you
Wow there is a more of a size to you
than the average person your age
that's okay Gina I know what it's like
to be more size size more you know like
down there the penis' people don't
really say Sizemore they they kind of
say size less there it's 2-2 I'm ashamed
of the it's thin and small to know with
the ones that were like you got a thick
dick right thanks Sizemore you really
Katie's porn talking now this man [ __ ]
you guys both of you out t I said don't
do that